in this segment we go through an example
to get some practice with Poisson
process calculations the example is as
follows you go fishing and fish are
caught according to a Poisson process
with an arrival rate that is the rate at
which fish are caught of 0.6 fish per
hour you will fish for two hours no
matter what and if during those two
hours you have caught at least one fish
then you stop as in this scenario in
which you have caught three fish during
the first two hours and then you stop
otherwise you will continue until you
catch one fish and at that time you will
stop we will answer a few questions and
we will write down the answers to these
questions in terms of the notation that
we have introduced and here for
reference we have all the formulas that
we have developed so far the first
question is what is the probability that
you get to fish for more than two hours
well you get to fish for more than two
hours if and only if you didn't catch
any fish during the first two hours so
this is the probability of catching zero
fish in the first two hours and we can
use this formula substitute K equal to
zero tau equal to two lambda equal to
0.6 plug in the numbers and obtain a
numerical answer we will not bother the
numerical answers we will just be
writing down the expressions that give
us the answers now in this question we
could have a different approach you will
fish for more than two hours if and only
if there are no arrivals during the
first two hours which means that the
first arrival in the Poisson process of
fishing happens after time two so we're
talking about the event that the first
arrival t1 is bigger than two and we're
looking into the probability of this
event which is the integral of the
density
the first arrival time and the integral
is taken over the range of values of
interest larger than two that is from
two to infinity we know that this
density is exponential so we can write
down this integral and evaluate it so
notice the difference between these two
approaches here we think in terms of the
random variables that correspond to the
number of arrivals during a certain time
interval here worth reasoning in terms
of inter arrival times and more
generally for Poisson process problems
an event of interest sometimes can be
expressed in terms of number of arrivals
or sometimes it can be expressed in
terms of arrival and inter arrival times
or sometimes both approaches are
possible but usually one of the two
approaches will be simpler than the
other for example here we already have a
formula whereas here we would need to
evaluate an integral here is now our
next question which is a little bit more
complicated what is the probability that
you get to fish for more than two hours
and also you get to fish for less than
five hours this is the scenario again
that you fish for more than two hours
which means that no fish were caught
during the first two hours and then you
continue fishing and by time five you
have already caught your fish and you
have left now it is convenient of
thinking about the Poisson process as
follows
think about the Poisson process of
catching fish at the rate of 0.6%
so there's a fisherman who fishes
forever except that this fisherman at
either this time under this scenario or
at that time under this scenario raises
a flag and says ok this is the time I
should be stopping so even though the
fisherman will stop fishing at this time
we can imagine that the Poisson process
keeps going
on with this way of thinking the fact
that you stopped fishing before time
five is the event that the number of
fish caught or the number of Poisson
arrivals during the interval from 2 to 5
is at least equal to 1
larger than or equal to 1 so the event
of interest consists of the intersection
of two events zero fish caught during
the first two hours which has this
probability and at least one arrival in
the Poisson process between times 2 & 5
this is a time interval of length 3 and
having at least one arrival is 1 minus
the probability of 0 arrivals in a time
interval of length 3 notice that I'm
multiplying those two probabilities here
why am i doing this in a Poisson process
whatever happens in this joint time
intervals are independent events so an
event having to do with this interval
the event that no fish were caught and
the event that has to do with this
interval at least one fish caught at
least one arrival during this time
interval these two events are
independent and this is why we can
multiply their probabilities now let us
think of the alternative approach a
different way of describing this event
using arrival and inter arrival times
what is this event this is the event
that no arrival happened until this time
but an arrival happened before time 5 so
this is the event that the first arrival
happens after time 2 but before time 5
and we're looking at the probability of
this event which we can find by
integrating the PDF of the first arrival
time from 2 until 5 the next question is
what is the probability that we catch at
least 2 fish under this scenario we
catch one fish and we stop
therefore this scenario must have
materialized the event of catching at
least two fish is the scenario that from
time from zero until - we caught at
least two fish so we're talking about
the probability of catching at least two
fish which is the probability of
catching a fish during a time interval
of length 2 where K can be anything from
2 to infinity so this is the probability
that the number of fish caught during
these two time units is at least equal
to 2 and an alternative way of writing
this expression so that we do not have
to evaluate an infinite sum it is 1
minus the probability of catching zero
fish and minus the probability of
catching one fish if we were to write
this in terms of arrival and inter
arrival times we will cut at least two
fish if and only if by the time we stop
which will be time - we've had two
arrivals which means that the second
arrival time happens before time - so
we're looking into the probability that
the second arrival time happens before
time - which is the integral from 0 to 2
of the density of the second arrival
time we have a formula for this density
given by the Erlang PDF so we could take
this expression plug it in here evaluate
the integral and obtain the same answer
as we would have obtained here clearly
in this case as well this first approach
would be simpler one because these
probabilities are already available to
us the next question is the following
suppose that you already fished for 3
hours this is something that can only
happen under this second scenario so no
fish have been caught until time 2
you continue no fish were caught until
time three and given that this event has
occurred what is the expected value of
the future fishing time the expected
value until a fish gets caught for the
first time
well the Poisson process starts fresh at
time three no matter what happens in the
past no matter what information were
given the past now you're sitting at
time three and looking into the future
you have a fresh starting Poisson
process as if this was the initial time
starting from this time the time until
the first arrival is going to have an
exponential distribution with parameter
lambda and the expected value of this
distribution is equal to 1 over lambda
finally let us look at a different type
of question what is the expected value
of the total time that you get to fish
let us introduce here some notation let
us call the total fishing time capital F
and the total fishing time consists of
two pieces there's the time until time
to that you will be fishing no matter
what and then there's going to be the
remaining fishing time after time two so
now let us look at the expectation of
the remaining fishing time after time
two here there are two scenarios in the
first scenario you stop in the second
scenario you continue and we will take
into account these two scenarios by
using the total expectation theorem the
first scenario happens with some
probability this is the probability that
you stop fishing at time 2 and in that
case your remaining fishing time is
going to be equal to 0
because you do not continue under that
scenario but there's the other scenario
that you get to fish for more than two
time units
and then we multiply this term with the
conditional expectation of the remaining
fishing time given that you got to fish
for more than two time units so what is
this term the probability that you get
to fish for more than two time units
this is the probability that no fish
were caught during the first time units
this is the probability of the second
scenario and then we have this
conditional expectation given that you
didn't catch anything and therefore you
will be continuing fishing what is the
expected amount of time
f-minus to that you will be fishing now
the Poisson process starts fresh at time
two so looking into the future were
faced with a photon process and we're
asking for the expected time until the
first arrival and this time has an
expected value equal to one over lambda
our last question is of a similar type
what is the expected number of fish you
are going to catch once more we will
break this into two pieces number of
fish caught during the first two hours
and number of fish caught during the
remaining hours during the first two
hours the expected number of fish that
you catch is given by this formula it is
equal to lambda tau and in our case
lambda is 0.6 and tau is equal to 2 plus
the expected number of fish that are
caught afterwards what is this expected
value again we think in terms of the
total expectation theorem there's one
scenario that has a certain probability
and under that scenario you do not catch
any fish
so that doesn't give us any contribution
then there is this scenario the second
one that has this probability of
occurring the probability of catching No
fish here so that the second scenario
materializes and if that second scenario
materializes how many fish are you going
to catch after time - it's going to be
one fish with certainty and this is the
final answer to this question
notice that in answering both of these
questions we use the divided conquer
strategy twice we first divided the time
horizon into two pieces and dealt
separately with each one of the pieces
and then in order to deal with this
circled piece the time after time - we
use divide and conquer into the two
different scenarios and using the total
expectation theorem